these days if you want to simulate
something in the physical world you use
a computer but what if you couldn't what
if it was say the 1950s and you used to
work out if a bold but questionable plan
to dam the San Francisco Bay was a good
idea the answer is this the US Army
Corps of Engineers they model the bay
model is one and a half acres or more
what you're looking at is one of our
former scientific hydrodynamic
engineering testing facilities and this
was the tool the instrument that they
used see what the unforeseen
consequences of the John River plan was
going to be in the 1940s and 50s a man
named John River had a plan to
completely change the San Francisco Bay
enormous dams would create freshwater
lakes they'd be brand new reclaimed land
for industry and for air and naval bases
River said it would make the Bay a
defensible military fortification move
people safely inland and the newly
dammed rivers would provide huge amounts
of drinking water Reba was not a
professional engineer he was a
theatrical producer who done a lot of
research but because he worked in
showbiz he knew how to promote something
and by most accounts he was a friendly
sincere convincing man so unlike other
ideas for giant engineering projects the
Reba plan actually caught on debate went
back and forth for years but eventually
Reba's plan seemed realistic enough at
least to politicians that the US Army
Corps of Engineers were tasked to see if
it was practical and they were given two
and a half million dollars that's about
25 million dollars today to find out and
with it they built this this model when
it was built was the next level the next
generation it was extremely accurate as
an instrument of time there really
wasn't anything better there's 250,000
strategically placed little copper tabs
in the bottom of the model to keep the
saltwater ever freshwater from going in
and out too quickly but also to
duplicate any little protrusions
sticking up out of the bottom of the
bait the model is one to a thousand
scale horizontally one to 100 scale
vertically and one to 100 scale in time
that means about 200 times a day the
tide comes in and the tide goes out
because
San Francisco Bay has tides in bat fall
so does the model everything was hand
operated for the first 30 years it took
probably anywhere between 12 and 15
people to operate it sometimes it was
many as sixty people here at one time
working on various different experiments
and everybody had to be totally in sync
it was like an orchestra and the interns
were out there in chairs in lab coats in
the water measuring the various
different Evan flow the type it took
three years for Reba's plan to be tested
here and in that time River passed away
and for his supporters the results from
the model were devastating it looked
great on paper convinced a lot of people
but when it was tested they found that
it was only good on paper the end result
was it failed on 99 different accounts
wild and unpredictable catastrophic
flooding was just one of them the dams
wouldn't create like they create
evaporation ponds the tide would create
dangerous currents and waves in short
not only would the river plan have been
a disaster it would have been a
billion-dollar disaster the ecosystem
would have been devastated too but it
was the 50s so no one was really
thinking about that the Corps of
Engineers their job done figured the
model would come in useful again someday
and it did helping to test smaller and
more practical schemes across the bay
for decades these days of course
computers can do all that for a fraction
of the time and the money but it's still
a good educational resource last time I
talked about a grand civil engineering
scheme like this about Hermon circles at
LAN tripper I said it was a testament to
how big we can dream but this model is a
testament to something else to science
to having a hypothesis to testing it and
then when it fails admitting that it's
wrong there shouldn't be any shame in
that
sometimes we follow bad ideas and
changing your mind based on new evidence
and allowing others to do the same is
something our world should be built on
and it's exactly what this model made
you